Ghost Recon wildlands will bring you new
experiences after its launch on March
7th with free updates seasonal events
community challenges as well as the
all-new PEP mode PvP will be a free
update for all Ghost Recon wildlands
owners offering tactical class-based or
v14 combat that will put your skills to
the test with the season pass you'll get
two expansions that introduce entirely
new experiences that you can play solo
or with a friend and co-op
in the first expansion narco road you'll
go undercover to gain the trust of three
new gangs and bring down their leaders
from within live the narco life as you
take on these fast-paced missions with
all new vehicles
the second expansion is falling ghosts
after your chopper is shot down during
an evacuation mission your squad will be
forced to adapt as their tracks down by
an elite group of ruthless mercenaries
the Ghost Recon wildlands
seasonpass comes packed with extra
content and perks including three ghost
packs an exclusive vehicle a permanent
XP boost and more plus get early access
to narco road and falling ghosts be on
the lookout for Ghost Recon wildlands
when it releases March 7 and stay tuned
for much more on the exciting new
content still
you
you